ah bah ça valait le coup ces deux
expositions super des photos sont
magnifiques et on est en manque de
photos de musée de peinture dont
heureusement
heureusement que les galeries existe
visiteurs habituels qui viennent dès
qu'on a une nouvelle expo nous on a
aussi plein de gens qui viennent parce
que les musées sont fermés et qui nous
disent merci
dès qu'ils passent la porte parce qu'ils
sont ravis de pouvoir avoir un lieu
culturel ouvert et une exposition et
visiter les galeries d'art c'est pas
juste un lieu pour
personne
financièrement capable d'acheter des
oeuvres c'est vraiment une exposition
comme son nom l indique c pour montrer
des oeuvres c'est pas spécifiquement
pour les vendre en tout cas c'est
accessible à tous